The line that runs down the middle dividing all of these even functions in half
is the y axis. So they have symmetry across the y axis. Just by looking we can
tell that they don't have symmetry across the x axis. In fact, none of these
even functions even have any points that lie below the x axis. So that means
that none of the points on them that lay above it, will have corresponding
points that there reflected across from. Now, these last two choices might look
a little bit complicated, but taking your time and thinking through them you can
figure out which one's true, if either one. Saying that f of negative x Is equal
to f of x, is basically saying that two points lie on a graph. This is the same
as saying that if we have the point x, y, or x, f of x, then we'll also have the
point negative x, y. This is saying that when you plug in the negative version
of some x value, you get the same y value since the value of the function is the
same at those two x coordinates. We already saw in the last quiz that this is in
fact true of even functions. So this also applies. The last answer does not,
since having it be true would mean that this third one couldn't be true.